going on a house you make sure no is  home okay bro what are we gonna do  but we're gonna be fine we just gotta  get enough money and get out of here  before anyone else gets hurt  [Music]  so what do you guys do when you're not  hijacking people's houses  [Music]  you know I got a plan for how we can all  be together you know that  is one of your doll houses available do  you like it here yeah so can you do as I  say and listen to me it's not really my  idea of a home it's a house a home is  what you build inside of it  I saw a beam struck my pinky's here and  if you see him you need to run you come  find me  all righty you said anything about  leaving  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  the mother will do anything to protect  her child  [Music]  you